DESERVE THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION AND YOU MIGHT DESERVE
TO HAVE IT STOLEN AGAIN FROM
YOU.
WITH REACTION, CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES.
CONGRESSMAN -- THAT LOOKS LIKE A
JOHN DEERE BEHIND HIM.
TRACTOR.
ONE OF THE GREAT AMERICAN
COMPANIES WE HAVE.
HE COMES FROM A FAMILY OF THREE
GENERATIONS OF FARMERS AND STILL
FARMS TODAY ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIA FARMER MATTHEW LATER
IS WITH US.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
MATTHEW, I WILL DEFER TO YOU.
I DON’T KNOW, I’M NOT A FARMER,
BUT I HAVE A DEEP RESPECT FOR
THE SCIENCE BEHIND FARMING.
THE CHEMICAL COMPOSITION OF THE
SOIL, WHAT YOU DO IN DROUGHT
YEARS WHEN YOU HAVE CERTAIN
DISEASES THAT POP UP.
CREATING STRONGER, MORE VIBRANT
PRODUCTS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, I WOULD THINK IT’S A
LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED THAN THE
WAY MAYOR BLOOMBERG OR FARMER
MIKE DESCRIBED IT, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO EDUCATE HIM?
>> ABSOLUTELY, SEAN.
IF MR. BLOOMBERG WOULD LIKE TO
COME TO THE COUNTY, I’D BE HAPPY
TO LEND HIM A PAIR OF MY BOOTS
AND HE CAN FOLLOW ME AROUND FOR
THREE DAYS AND SHOW THEM JUST
HOW MUCH SCIENCE AND GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AND GOVERNMENT GOING
THROUGH THE REGULATIONS ON HOW
JUST TO EVERYDAY TURN ON THE
WATER, IRRIGATE OUR CROPS, DO
PEST AND DISEASE PREVENTION.
I MEAN IT’S --
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU FARM OUT
THERE?
>> WAY SMARTER.
I FARM CITRUS AND ALMONDS.
>> Sean: WATCH AND ALMONDS?
>> CITRUS AND OMENS.
>> Sean: AWESOME, BECAUSE WE
NEED THAT FOOD BURIED >> ORANGES
AND LEMONS.
>> Sean: I’VE NEVER HAD A
BETTER ORANGE IN MY LIFE THAN
WHEN I LIVED IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR A KID FROM NEW YORK, THAT
WAS A PARTICLE EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCE FOR THE FIRST TIME.
CONGRESSMAN NUNES, I DID NOT
KNOW THAT YOUR FAMILY WAS
INVOLVED IN THE FARMING INDUSTRY
FOR ALL THESE YEARS.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR BACKGROUND
WITH THIS.
>> THANK YOU, SEAN.
AS YOU REMEMBER ABOUT TEN YEARS
AGO YOU CAME OUT HERE TO THE
VALLEY TO LOOK AT THE IRRIGATION
SYSTEMS.
THIS IS THE VALLEY WHERE THE
BREADBASKET OF THE SOLAR SYSTEM
WOULD LIKE TO SAY.
300 DIFFERENT CROPS GROW HERE.
AND IT TAKES A HELL OF A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE TO DO THAT.
GENERATIONS OF FARMERS, IT’S
VERY SCIENTIFIC, AS YOU SAID.
MIKE BLOOMBERG SEEMS TO THINK
THAT THIS IS JUST LIKE BUYING A
CHIA PET AT WALMART.
AND PUTTING SOME WATER ON IT.
THAT’S NOT HOW THIS WORKS.
IT IS QUITE COMPLICATED AND IT’S
NOT JUST THE FARMERS, IT’S
GETTING THAT FOOD SAFELY ALL THE
WAY TO A GROCERY STORE IN
MANHATTAN SO THAT IT DOESN’T
POISON SOMEONE.
SO THERE’S A LOT THAT GOES INTO
IT AND LOOK, THIS IS REALLY ON
THE CRAZY METER, AS YOU JUST
SAID.
IF DONALD TRUMP WOULD HAVE SAID
ANYTHING LIKE THIS HE WOULD BE
HOUNDED AD NAUSEAM HIM UNTIL HE
RETRACTED THIS CRAZY STATEMENT
AND YOU PROBABLY WON’T SEE
ANYBODY APPROACH THEM AT THE
DEBATE TOMORROW NIGHT ABOUT THIS
CRAZY STATEMENT.
>> Sean: CAN I ASK YOU -- SO
WE HAVE HIM TAKING MULTIPLE
SHOTS AGAINST MINORITIES AND
WOMEN AND FARMERS, NEEDING MORE
GRAY MATTER.
WE ARE ABOUT TO REPORT SOME
BREAKING NEWS ABOUT COMMENTS
HE’S MADE IN THE PAST ABOUT
GAYS,, TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS,
IS UNDER FIRE FOR REFERRING TO
TRANSGENDER WOMEN AS SOME GUY
WEARING A DRESS, USING IT AS
A PRONOUN.
IF I DON’T KNOW, HOW’S THAT
GOING TO GO OVER WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE, DEVON?
>> WELL, LOOK, THEY ARE IN
DISARRAY RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THEY ARE IN DENIAL THAT
SOCIALIST BERNIE HAD A CHANCE TO
WIN THE NOMINATION.
AND WHAT’S HAPPENED HERE, AND
I’D SAID THIS BEFORE, THEY ARE
THE PARTY, THEY ARE LIKE THE DOG
THAT CAUGHT THE CAR, SO THEY’VE
BEEN LETTING THE SOCIALISM
LEACH OUT ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
AND OUR BIG CITIES SO MUCH THAT
THEY POISON THEIR OWN VOTING
BASE TO WHERE NOW
BERNIE SANDERS, A POLL JUST OUT
HOURS AGO, IS DOUBLING UP HIS
NEAREST OPPONENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
HE’S WINNING NEVADA.
SO LOOK, I THINK IT’S HIGHLY
LIKELY BERNIE AS THEIR NOMINEE.
THAT’S WHY THERE NOW, THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE ESTABLISHMENT
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY
ARE PLEADING FOR BLOOMBERG, JUST
SPEND MORE OF HER MILLIONS, WITH
GOT TO STOP BURNING.
THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENING.
SPEEONE’S OF THE PRESIDENT I
BELIEVE, CONGRESSMAN NUNES,
RIGHTLY SO, IS FRUSTRATED AND
NOW SPEAKING OUT.
WE HAVE ALL THIS EVIDENCE,
PREMEDITATED FRAUD, FISA COURT.
USING HILLARY’S BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR DIRTY DOSSIER, TO A LAW
FIRM, COULD BE A
CAMPAIGN FINANCE ISSUE.
SHE NEVER GOT IN TROUBLE FOR THE
ESPIONAGE ACT AND HAVING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON A
SERVER.
IN ORDER TO GET IN TROUBLE FOR
SUBPOENAED EMAILS THAT SHE
DELETED AND ACID WATCHED WITH
BLEACH BIT.
THEN OF COURSE NOT ONLY
PREMEDITATED THOUGHT FRAUD, BUT
THIS BY DONNA RESIDENT A CANDIDA
A TRANSITION TEAM DEEP INTO A
PLEASANT C.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT’S ALSO THE
OUTSOURCING OF SPYING ABROAD TO
ALLIED INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES TO
CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN LAWS.
THE PRESIDENT I THINK HAS A
RIGHT TO BE FRUSTRATED, BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE -- AND I’M NOT -- I
BELIEVE -- I BELIEVE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS DOING HIS
JOB, I REALLY BELIEVE IT.
I THINK IS GETTING TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT.
I THINK IT’S A HARD DIG BUT I
UNDERSTAND THE THE PRESIDENTS
FRUSTRATION ALSO.
>> YEAH, THE PRESIDENT HAS
ACTUALLY, SEAN, IT’S GOING TO BE
HERE TOMORROW, IS GOING TO BE
OUT IN THE VALLEY TOMORROW AND
I’M GOING TO HAVE A CHANCE TO
TALK TO HIM.
I’M SURE THIS WILL COME UP ON
WHAT IS THE FISA COURT GOING TO
LOOK LIKE IN THE FUTURE.
THAT’S SOMETHING THAT’S GOT TO
BE FIXED.
THIS TWO-TIER JUSTICE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY IS
JUST TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
BUT BACK TO THE TOPIC YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT IRRIGATION
TECHNOLOGY, YOU WERE OUT HERE
TEN YEARS AGO --
CAME OUT HERE TO THE VALLEY TWO
TIMES AND HE UNDERSTANDS THAT
WATER IS THE KEY TO LIFE.
THE UNDERSTANDS THESE PROJECTS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT, SO HE’S
GOING TO BE COMING OUT TOMORROW
TO ANNOUNCE EVEN IN
CALIFORNIA -- IS GOING TO COME
OUT HERE AND ANNOUNCE THAT HE’S
GOING TO OPEN UP MORE WATER FOR
FARMERS, THAT MIKE BLOOMBERG MAY
NOT UNDERSTAND WE ACTUALLY NEED
WATER TO FARM HERE.
>> Sean: GOOD OLD FARMER MIKE.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU.
MATT, THANK YOU, AND THANK YOU
TO ALL THE FARMERS THAT FEED THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY, THAT WORKED SO
HARD UNDER DIFFICULT CONDITIONS.
MASTERING THE SCIENCE OF
AGRICULTURE, AT SUCH A
SOPHISTICATED LEVEL.
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT SEEM TO
NEED ANY GRAY MATTER OF THE